sécurité puisque Gérald darmann en
présence une loi sur ce sujet de notre
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour augmenter les effectifs
augmenter les moyens justement Gérald
Darmanin Jérémy il était auditionné hier
au Sénat sur ce sujet par la commission
des lois oui tout à fait le ministre de
l'Intérieur a répondu aux questions des
sénateurs notamment donc sur le projet
de loi Love Me donc on appelle le projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'intérieur on le
rappelle le texte arrivera au Sénat
début octobre et prévoit notamment le
recrutement de 8500 policiers gendarmes
sur cinq ans et une augmentation de 15
milliards d'euros du budget du ministère
de l'Intérieur la moitié de cette
enveloppe servira le ministre la redit à
la transformation numérique du ministère
un point central sur lequel Gérald
Darmanin a insisté lors de son audition
je vous propose de l'écouter avec la
réaction ensuite du sénateur Mark
Philippe de Bresse
50% aujourd'hui des de la délinquance
financière et de l'escroquerie qui
touche les PME nos concitoyens les
hôpitaux enfin bref les collectivités
locales toutes petites soient-elles sont
d'origine cyber c'est déjà 50% de cette
délinquance de escroquerie mais c'est le
cas désormais dans la quasi intégralité
la délinquance y compris de voie
publique que nous connaissons et il faut
que la voiture
numérique ou technologique du policier
ou de gendarme aille aussi vite que la
voiture technologique des voleurs ou des
délinquants vous voulez être le ministre
de la cyber délinquance du 21e siècle
comme Clémenceau a été celui des
Brigades du Tigre du 20e siècle très
bien
une petite pique assez gentille
[Rires]
les mesures fortes sur la transformation
numérique 1600 postes de cyber
patrouilleur la possibilité de déposer
plainte en visio ou encore la création
du projet réseau radio du futur qui
coûtera 2 milliards d'euros pour
coordonner en fait les actions des
policiers gendarmes et pompiers
notamment lors des grandes crises que
traverse le pays on va continuer à
parler évidemment de ce texte mais
d'abord sur ce sujet Jean-Michel
chausseur vous qu'il connaissait
parfaitement bien vous êtes sociologue
ancien commandant de police je le
rappelle est-ce que pour vous c'est une
bonne loi c'est la loi qui va dans le
bon sens est-ce que ça répond aux
besoins actuels
ça répond aux besoinsctuels en essayant
de faire en sorte que les policiers qui
courent après la délinquance et
peut-être pour une fois un coup d'avance
on le voit notamment sur les annonces
concernant le concernant le numérique
après pour le reste il faut attendre bon
cette forme de planification sur 5 ans
est une bonne chose parce que elle
évitera peut-être
ce que les policiers ont connu depuis de
très nombreuses années c'est-à-dire une
suite de rendez-vous ratée
il y avait jamais de vision à long terme
c'est ça c'est le problème d'une part il
n'y a pas de vision long terme et
d'autre part il y a aussi un problème
d'évaluation des effets sur le terrain
cette huile l'évaluation et quelque
chose qui pêche qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas mise en oeuvre outre rarement mise
en oeuvre il faut dire aussi que le
ministère de l'Intérieur est par
définition le le ministère de l'urgence
le ministère de la réaction et
l'évaluation sur des politiques de long
terme c'est quelque chose que n'est pas
encore très très bien au point et le
problème a conduit d'ailleurs pendant de
nombreuses années c'est pour ça que je
parlais de rendez-vous non abouti à des
des volontés de modification ou des
modifications par par des lois des
changements etc des réformes qui ont été
changés avant qu'on mesure les effets
une mesure en chasse en une autre etc
c'est vrai que le long terme est quelque
chose qui pose problème dans
l'institution policière
sur la programmation moi je pense que il
est essentiel d'avoir une loi et une
vision sur cinq ans ça évite comme
monsieur l'a dit des coupes budgétaires
de Bercy on sait très bien comment se
monte un budget il faut faire des
arbitrages parfois là au moins c'est
gravé dans le marbre pour 5 ans mais
l'objet d'une part une remarque sur la
forme de cette loi c'est une loi qui
avait été présentée en mars dernier il y
avait 32 articles on en est plus qu'à 16
et quand on regarde bien le premier
article renvoie à une annexe de 82 pages
là où sont en fait ces mesures que vous
avez clairement décrit la création de
8500 policiers de s'embrigades
territorial de gendarmerie etc c'est un
peu surprenant quand même de demander au
parlementaire d'approuver ou de ne pas
approuver un seul et unique article on
aurait aimé aussi discuter sur le fond
de ces mesures la deuxième
soit ton vote l'article premier soit on
ne le vote pas donc c'est un peu quand
même bizarre en terme de discussion
parlementaires c'est du tout ou rien et
nous ne sommes pas habitués à ça si tu
m'étonnes assez surprenant deuxième
aspect de de la chose c'est que oui il y
a beaucoup de choses sur la
cybercrimanité les violences intrafes
familiales et également la filière
investigation mais il y a des zones
blancs blanches des zones d'ombres
s'agissant notamment des personnes en
charge de l'autorité publique il n'y a
pas de réponse on va me dire c'est pas
ce texte là mais il y a 90% du texte qui
modifie le Code pénal et le code de
procédure pénale deuxième aspect sur
l'immigration pareil pas de peine
plancher pas de double peine là aussi
c'est criant on parlera sans doute du
refus d'obtempérer quel message dans la
loi quelle disposition
Emmanuel Macron c'est un autre texte qui
arrive à lui début 2023 à force de
morceler les textes effectivement on n'a
pas une vision globale au niveau de la
chaîne pénale immigration et en tout cas
sur le la chaîne pénale je pense qu'il
faudrait une réflexion qui soit globale
ça a été demandé par le procure en
moulins hier matin dans le cadre de son
édition également là on morcelle en fait
les choses et on a pas cette vision
globale ce qui est à mon avis déplorable
Jean-Michel vous le disait effectivement
les textes se sont enchaînés les
réformes se sont enchaînées est-ce que
pour vous celle-là c'est une réforme de
plus ou est-ce que c'est une réforme
différente c'est une réforme de plus qui
apporte qui apporte des choses
intéressantes sur lesquelles sur
certains points moi je suis
personnellement un petit peu dans les
spectative attendons mais je pense
notamment à cette partie de la réforme
de la procédure pénale sur l'arrivée des
entre guillemets des des greffiers de
police je me suis un peu réservé je veux
pas rentrer dans le détail parce que
c'est du droit ces techniques c'est de
la procédure et il faut être versé à
cette chose là pour bien comprendre d'où
la difficulté pour les néophytes de de
bien comprendre les tenants et les abris
tout ça cette qu'est-ce que ça peut
apporter et qu'est-ce que ça n'apporte
pas on pourrait faire le lien d'ailleurs
avec le
ce qui concerne la police judiciaire qui
est en souffrance en ce moment avec les
annonces qui qui sont faites là aussi ça
renvoie des problématiques
professionnelles qui sont assez
complexes et on n'a pas le temps et de
rentrer dans le détail mais moi je me
suis assez foncé sur sur certaines
mesures effectivement je suis d'accord
avec monsieur le sénateur on ne voit que
une partie des choses et il manque cette
cette globalité alors
s'agissant notamment effectivement des
migrations mais s'agissant également des
problèmes de justice alors moi j'irai
pas jusqu'à dire que le problème de la
police et la justice mais je crois que
dans une forme de de globalité de
construction globale on ne peut plus
aujourd'hui faire l'impasse d'une
discussion ouverte et élargie à la fois
à la police et à la justice parce que ça
les deux choses vont inévitablement
ensemble notamment et surtout en matière
de procédure pénale j'ajoute qu'on a eu
le bobo de la sécurité on a eu les états
généraux de la justice il serait bon de
voir en fait c'est les recommandations
de part et d'autre et de faire justement
une réflexion globale et d'avoir un
texte global
la conclusion du bobo de la sécurité
justement de programmation mais ça ne
prend pas en compte c'est assez criant
parce qu'il y a un matin on avait
justement le compte rendu des états
généraux de la justice il y avait des
recommandations qui me paraissaient
intéressantes mais qui n'apparaissent
pas dans ce texte et je pense que c'est
ces déplorable encore une fois encore
des difficultés justice à travailler
ensemble non non ça n'a rien à voir je
pense qu'il y a une volonté politique à
mettre le ministère de la Justice et le
ministère de l'Intérieur a travaillé sur
un texte commun arrêtons de renvoyer
quand j'entends le ministre Darmanin
dire oui mais alors ça vous savez vous
verrez ça avec Monsieur Dupont-Moretti
non la vie c'est pas ça la chaîne pénale
on dit pas bah oui ça vous verrez ça
avec les yeux c'est c'est pas comme ça
en tout cas qu'on qu'on améliorera à mon
avis qu'on obtenisera la chaîne
Jean-Michel Chaussin ou sur le terrain
aussi vous ressentez ces difficultés de
coordination police
que ça dépend des directions et ça
dépend du ça dépend du travail en ce qui
concerne l'activité d'investigation
l'activité judiciaire ça ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne bien même s'il peut y
avoir ici ou là des disparités des
choses qui ne passent pas toujours parce
qu'il y a des ignorance ou quelquefois
des mécontentement
du notamment la politique pénale enfin
en tout cas la poursuite
mais dans l'ensemble
la chaîne fonctionne bien pour autant
elle demande bien évidemment d'être
améliorée c'est pas pour rien que les
policiers demandent depuis des années
au-delà des réformes structurelles ou
économiques qui leur sont proposées
quelque chose qui soit mis en oeuvre au
niveau justement des poursuites et de la
politique pénales qui définissent une
vraie philosophie de l'action plutôt
qu'une réponse encore une fois dans
l'urgence
d'autres sujets sur lequel les
sénatériaires ont interrogé Gérald
Darmanin Jérémy c'est le partage
territorial entre les zones de police et
de gendarmerie oui c'est le dernier de
question qui revient bon le ministre
d'armanin est resté assez flou
finalement il a il a pas totalement
répondu il a assuré que plutôt que de
penser en territoire il préférait se
concentrer en zone de délinquance et
donc envoyer soit la police soit la
gendarmerie là où elle sera la plus
utile peu importe finalement le
territoire crée des sortes de continuité
d'action peu importe les frontières
territoriales mais il a aussi rappelé
une volonté de décentraliser les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur en
rouvrant notamment ce qui est prévu dans
le projet de loi des sous-préfectures en
zone rurale et en envoyant il la redit
1500 employés du ministère de
l'Intérieur en dehors de Paris par
exemple l'IGPN devrait aller au Havre
est-ce que c'est vous avez été satisfait
de cette réponse Stéphane Le redulliez
et sur la question de la ruralité
puisque c'est important ce projet de loi
il prévoit aussi de créer des brigades
de gendarmerie en zone rurale ça c'est
une quelque chose alors tout ce qui va
effectivement
dans l'amélioration des services publics
parce que la sécurité une brigade
d'astéritoriale de gendarmerie ou
un commissariat c'est aussi un service
public il y a pas que des gardes à vue
dans un commissariat donc effectivement
ça va dans le bon sens puisque on
réinjecte en fait des services publics
au niveau de la réalité juste un point
parce que je vous ai dit il y a 16
articles qui sont tombés
on n'a pas assez parlé d'un des axes que
Monsieur Darmanin avait pourtant
développé au mois de mars c'est le
continuum sécurité puisqu'on parle de
ruralité entre
force de l'ordre national et police
municipale il y avait quand même deux
mesures phares qui avaient été réclamés
par l'Association des maires de France
notamment le fait que la commune puisse
porter partie civile dès lors qu'un élu
et en fait agress ou impacté par un
crime ou un délit premièrement cette
disposition a totalement disparu du
texte réponse de Monsieur Darmanin si
vous voulez à la introduire il y a pas
de souci bon c'est surprenant deuxième
point c'est le droit funéraire pour
dégager notamment des forces de police
nationale de tout ce qui est surveillant
et seulement d'un cercueil il était
prévu que le maire avec les agents
municipaux ou la police municipale
puisse faire ses opérations et que il y
a une compensation financière à travers
la loi de finance vous voyez ce
continuum ça sert aussi à optimiser le
temps de travail des forces de police
nationale et à bien répartir les tâches
et ça c'est un manque évident au niveau
une insuffisance au niveau de ce texte
sur ce sujet Jean-Michel chausseur à la
fois sur ce continent de sécurité et sur
ce partage des interrupteurs anthropolis
et gendarmerie il y a encore du travail
là dessus
il y a encore du travail de choses d'une
part le ministre semblerait vouloir
désormais en quelque sorte certaines
unités voire certaines actions de police
et dans le même temps ce qui peut
sembler assez contradictoires
la police judiciaire j'y reviens elle se
verrait amputée d'une partie de ses
prérogatives en matière de de territoire
puisque repasserait si je puis dire sous
les fourches claudines départementales
alors qu'elles sont depuis Clémenceau
régional et même interrégional
maintenant avec tout ce que ça suppose
en termes de poursuite des des
opérations ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point je trouve qu'on devrait
de plus en plus aller vers une forme de
synergie police nationale police
municipale on l'a bien fait dans le
cadre de la synergie police gendarmerie
est Dieu sait que les les c'était pas
forcément évident au départ je crois
qu'il faut y arriver il y a eu quelques
années des discussions qui étaient
intéressantes est nécessaire et légitime
sur une forme de privatisation du
principe de sécurité qui reste un des
grands points de la politique régalienne
bien évidemment en disant avec ce fameux
débat sur les communeries chez les
communes riches je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on doit dépasser ce débat
la teneur et l'ampleur de la violence et
de la délinquance en règle générale
nécessite à mon avis qui est une un
meilleur emploi une meilleure fusion
entre police municipale et police
nationale et quand on parle
d'intelligence des territoires en voilà
un exemple justement puisque vous parlez
de ce sujet on va aller dans une commune
à petit quevillée c'est dans la banlieue
de Rouen face à la hausse des
incivilités le maire en a appelé à
l'état on regarde sur portage de Cécile
Siksou
un petit-quevill dans la banlieue de
Rouen la délinquance a augmenté après le
confinement homicide violence trafic de
drogue la mère qui ne pouvait plus
répondre aux demandes de sécurité de ses
administrés a décidé en octobre 2021 de
faire appel au ministre de l'intérieur
avec 35 maires des communes voisines
impactées par les mêmes phénomènes elle
a demandé plus de policiers donc moi
j'ai décidé de
saisir avec d'autres maires parce qu'on
faisait le constat aussi parallèlement
que les habitants faisaient appel à la
police nationale et qu'on leur répondait
que voilà il ne pouvait pas se déplacer
et donc les habitants se retournaient
vers nous forcément face à cette
difficulté et donc on a lancé avec
plusieurs maires
d'abord un courrier de courrier réponse
du ministre il promet le déploiement de
force de l'ordre supplémentaires sur le
territoire l'affectation de 60 policiers
à la circonscription de Rouen Elbeuf au
1er 2022 et il indique bien que ce sont
des créations nettes d'éventuelles
départs sauf que depuis si effectivement
certains policiers sortis d'écoles ont
été recrutés ils ne font que remplacer
les départs à la retraite et les
mutations l'annonce la semaine dernière
du recrutement de 30 policiers
supplémentaires dans le cadre de la loi
loopy sur le territoire ou années ne
convainc pas non plus la mer elle a
lancé une pétition dans sa commune pour
mobiliser la population merci on en est
où alors du nombre de signatures
gardant la métropole de Rouen difficile
pour la police d'assurer ses missions
correctement au syndicat SGP où l'on
accueille les nouveaux venus on estime
qu'il faudrait sans policiers
supplémentaires pour travailler
correctement
on a baissé le nombre de policiers et
maintenant on se rend compte que
finalement des policiers on en a besoin
on voit alors on parle de on parle de la
voie publique on parle de aussi de
l'investigation avec les dossiers qui
montent on a des policiers qui ont des
dossiers mais ils arriveront ils
pourront pas traiter tous ces dossiers
là on a le la difficulté aujourd'hui à
recevoir correctement le public
on a des gens qui viennent déposer
plainte on peut plus assurés enfin un
peu plus surré on assure toutes les
plaintes mais il y a beaucoup d'attentes
quand même des plaintes non déposées au
manque d'intervention à Rouen c'est
surtout la nuit que le manque de
personnel se fait ressentir souvent le
17 ne répond même pas comme la constater
Kader chez kemani en charge de la
tranquillité publique à la ville vous
subissez un tapage nocturne vous devenez
tout simplement fou et si personne ne
répond il y a de quoi les gens
excusez-moi péter les plombs et là du
coup ça génère d'autres problématiques
et si on répond pas dès le premier dès
la première activité très rapidement et
bah ça peut prendre des proportions qui
sont pas du tout contrôlables par la
suite et c'est là où on arrive à des
drames parce que tout simplement une
personne ne dure pas pendant 8 jours
parce que il y a quelqu'un qui fait la
fête à côté pour compenser Kader chic et
Mani a multiplié les installations de
vidéosurveillance et recrutés 11
policiers municipaux qui travailleront
pour la brigade de nuit dès 2023
recruté sont actuellement en formation
et le calendrier tel qu'on l'avait fixé
sera tenue c'est-à-dire un déploiement
sur le terrain de la nuit à partir du
1er trimestre 2023
va prendre conscience des besoins criant
sur le territoire et tenir sa promesse
d'envoyer 30 policiers supplémentaires
car la nouvelle brigade de nuit va
coûter à la ville de Rouen 600000 euros
par an les élus estiment qu'ils ne
pourront pas indéfiniment supporter la
mission de sécurité de l'État
un secret d'alarme d'un maire Stéphane
le robinier est-ce qu'il y a un décalage
entre ce qui est promis par l'État et ce
qui arrive concrètement sur le terrain
incontestablement je dirais oui il y a
je pense des promesses sur les 8500
ouverture de poste après dans dans la
réalité on s'aperçoit parfois que des
postes ouverts ne sont pas forcément
pourvu ce que disait la mère c'est on
était en train de parler du continent de
sécurité on est en plein dedans
c'est vrai que parfois des et souvent il
y a des conventions de coordination
entre les forces de police nationale où
les forces de l'ordre national et les
communes c'est un parfait exemple avec
la mise en oeuvre et des moyens
financiers portés par les communes de
plus de 600.000 euros pour avoir une
brigade de nuit derrière ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que on doit considérer
cela comme un désengagement de l'État
par rapport aux communes je ne pense pas
je pense qu'il doit y avoir une
coordination intelligente entre les
forces de l'ordre national les communes
et derrière aider
des communes alors dans le texte il y a
le FIPD qui a été le fond intercommunal
de la prévention de la délaiquence qui a
été multiplié par 3 en tout cas c'est
cette trajectoire mais ce n'est axé
spécifiquement que sur la
vidéoprotection ce qui est bien ce qui
est une bonne chose mais peut-être qu'il
y a d'autres formes d'aide de
développement notamment en termes de
moyens humains des polices municipales
j'ajoute un point le spectre de dire
attention développons par exemple des
missions de police judiciaire au niveau
des polices municipales prononce là
quand même avec des pincettes puisque
les mers sont opposés à juste titre que
les polices municipales soient
rattachées au procure la République dans
le cadre de ses missions sur ce sujet
je suis assez d'accord même si la police
municipale peut servir de d'appui de
très intéressant et très important pour
traiter nombre d'incivilités ou de toute
petite délinquance qui sont les
problématiques principales auxquelles
les citoyens ont à faire face juste une
petite précision tout de même sur les
renforts policiers très souvent on
oublie de dire où on passe légèrement
sous silence le fait des départs en
retraite des mutations qui obèrent plus
que largement le nombre total de
policiers qui sont mis à disposition et
enfin si vous me permettez cette
parallèle militaire bon malheureusement
d'actualité aujourd'hui les policiers
connaissent bien ça aussi pour un
combattant de l'avant combien de
logisticiens derrière et il en est de la
même chose pour les policiers pour un
policier qui va être sur la voie
publique combien il y en a-t-il au
commissariat ça veut dire qu'il faut
remettre les policiers sur le terrain
ils font trop de tâches administratives
aujourd'hui sache l'entends dire depuis
les années 1980 donc il y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil malheureusement
il faut mettre des policiers sur le
terrain mais encore faut-il avoir les
possibilités la possibilité de les
mettre sur le terrain et pour avoir 100%
de policiers en plus sur le terrain
c'est pas 8000 policiers qu'il faudrait
en plus c'est beaucoup plus ne peut pas
l'alchiffrer évidemment mais
il y a des des contingences intérieures
[Musique]
au Parlement Stéphane lerudulier
évidemment vous vous suivez sera prêt et
on aura l'occasion d'avoir d'autres
débats sur ce sujet
[Musique]